hello everyone it's seven o'clock this
is Sky News breakfast the 15th and 20th
of December it's been revealed this
morning that those are the two days when
nurses will stage their first national
walkout across England Wales and
Northern Ireland we'll speak to the
Royal College of Nursing as fellow
Health unions bring pay rounds to a head
with industrial action throughout the
NHS and GPS push to cut their core hours
also this morning a big day for the home
nations of the world cup with Wales and
England gearing up for their second
games and fans are told that they can
wear rainbow hats and flags it's Friday
the 25th of November
nurses are to strike for two days in
December the first of what could be
several walkouts overpay NHS Chiefs
believe there's now no way to avert it
pay is a matter for the government but
our job in the NHS is to prepare for
what looks like inevitable industrial
action and
straining under record waiting list
ahead of a winter to endemic or flu and
covet
as England and Wales prepare for today's
games FIFA lifts its ban on Rainbow
clothing and flags at World Cup matches
also this morning police and prosecutors
to be given more criminal Powers against
those who share intimate and private
images of people online without consent
after inviting Donald Trump back Twitter
owner Elon Musk announces more suspended
accounts will have their bands lifted
Keira Knightley lends her voice to a
very personal book about the war in
Ukraine we'll speak to the 12 year old
girl who wrote it
and a special delivery we'll hear how
this huge gorilla has been brought to
London in an attempt to help save his
species
[Music]
hello everybody good morning you're
watching Sky News breakfast
Union has revealed the two days that its
members will go on strike next month in
a dramatic escalation of the pay
disputes that are raging across the NHS
well they're planned to go ahead on
Thursday the 15th and Tuesday the 20th
of December
the Royal College of Nursing says
intensive care and a e services will not
be affected but there will be disruption
for routine care and planned surgery
the strikes will happen across England
Wales and Northern Ireland but not at
this stage in Scotland where
negotiations are ongoing
the Royal College of Nursing wants an
overall pay rise of more than 19 percent
which the government says it's simply
can't afford NHS bosses say their focus
is on limiting delays and cancellations
as much as possible
of course pay is a matter for the
government but our job in the NHS is to
prepare for what looks like inevitable
industrial action and I think it's
inevitable that if strike action goes
ahead there will be some disruption uh
if you're a member of the public of
course keep that appointment that you've
got unless you are contacted and told
that you're outpatient appointment isn't
going ahead or your operation might not
be going ahead but of course from the
NHS point of view we want to make sure
that we keep things obviously safe but
we do as much as we possibly can while
recognizing of course the right of our
rights of our staff to take strike
action
well I correspondent Melena vaselinovich
is outside the Royal College of
nursing's headquarters in central London
Forest so Milena the dates have been
announced then for this strike the first
in the Union's history so it's a big
moment just how disruptive could it be
for patients do we think
well routine appointments routine
surgeries they will inevitably be
canceled but Urgent Care will continue
and that's because unlike other
professions there will be a number of
nurses that will be exempt from Strike
action in order to keep patients safe to
you but it will be that patients will
suffer now the question is whether those
trust where strikes will take place
could fill those gaps with agency nurses
well they could they could entice them
with high pay even though the Royal
College of Nursing advice to them is
also clear that they expect them not to
fill the shifts of the Striking workers
however they are not obliged to do that
and what the nurses say they want is 17
at least a pay rise because they say
that low wages have driven staff out of
the profession in fact they have
commissioned some research which found
that in 2010 a pay for a senior nurse
was actually in real terms 20 percent
higher than it is today and they say
that just in the last year 25
000 people have left the profession now
on the other hand Steve Barkley the
health secretary says that that kind of
an increase is unaffordable in the
current economic climate that it'll cost
10 billion pounds now you know nurses in
turn also say that actually it costs
quite a lot of money to pay agency
nurses to plug these constant gaps in
Staffing it's not just a one-off it just
runs on a constant deficit of staff and
they say that that puts patience and
risk of course it will be patients who
will bear the brunt of it as well as
that heaving NHS backlog that is about
to get even bigger
okay Melina thanks very much indeed
well meanwhile a winter of discontent
seems very much on the horizon with
nurses now joining Railway staff postal
workers University lecturers in Striking
within the next month our business and
economics correspondent gurpreet narwan
has been assessing how disruptive
strikes have been to the UK economy this
year
at times it can feel like everyone in
Britain is going on strike but how
significant is this industrial action in
a historical context and should we
really be bracing ourselves for another
winter of discontent let's take a look
at the number of working days lost to
strike action now this is the number of
workers on strike multiplied by the
number of days they've not worked and it
doesn't look that significant in recent
years not like the 2011 public sector
strikes or the 2014 public sector
strikes but it has been climbing during
the pandemic the line is flat because
statisticians stopped collecting the
data this chart it goes up to Augusta
expecting it to climb a lot higher we
know that up to 40 000 Railway workers
and up to 300 000 nurses are braced to
go on strike before Christmas and these
strikes they're going to be pretty
short-lived there's been a shift towards
shorter bursts of action between one and
three days
nothing like the 1980s when you could
see strike action last well into a year
and which sectors are driving this
increase well you may have guessed it's
the transport and communication sectors
that includes Railway workers it
includes postal workers and the number
of working days lost to strike action in
these sectors it's at its highest since
records began in 2008. and why are
workers going on strike well quite
simply because their pay is not keeping
up with inflation here you can see the
blue bars show real wages rising and the
red bars show real wages falling that
means wages are not keeping up with
inflation and since November last year
wages have been falling so after a
decade of wage stagnation workers are
not prepared to see their living
standards fall even further but all of
this strike action it does come with the
cost to the economy
and we're asking this morning if you
have an appointment or an operation
which is set to be impacted by the
strides do get in touch with us um with
that industrial action how it might be
affecting you you can email us at
sky.today at sky.uk or you can send a
WhatsApp message to
07583 Triple zero eight five three let
us know how you might be affected well
meanwhile GPS want to pressure the
government to cut their core hours to
nine to five nine a.m to 5 p.m GP bodies
object to the current extended hours
contract which requires doctors to see
patients on weekday evenings between 6
30 and 8 PM they say these for hours
unfairly impact on GPS who have families
the latest NHS data shows one in five
consultations were held more than a
fortnight after they were booked
so let's take a look now at what's
making the front pages of the morning
papers and despite growing NHS waiting
lists the mail covers that report about
GPS that they're demanding that in
future they work just nine to five
the times meanwhile says that
middle-income households are to receive
grants worth up to fifteen thousand
pounds to help insulate their homes
the eye says there's likely to be
conflict in the cabinet over plans to
withhold visas from foreign students
pursuing what are described as low
quality degrees in an effort to reduce
net migration
first class disgrace says the mirror
which says Royal Mail has paid out
almost 2 billion pounds to shareholders
since privatization but still won't give
its staff a decent pay rise
The Daily Telegraph says Boris Johnson
and Liz truss are planning to challenge
the authority of new PM Rishi sunak by
demanding an end to the ban on new
onshore wind farms
and the guardian says MPS want an
investigation into claims against the
Tory Pier baroness moan about payments
she allegedly received from her ties to
a PPE manufacturer during the pandemic
allegations that she's denied
now let's turn our attention to the
World Cup in Qatar where FIFA Has Lifted
its ban on Rainbow clothes and flags for
fans ahead of two home Nations games for
Wales and England today fans have so far
been stopped from wearing rainbow bucket
hats to matches and there's been a
contentious debate about players
weighing armbands in support of lgbtq
plus rights well later this morning
whales play Iran and then later it's
England versus the US and managers
insist their sides shouldn't feel
pressured to protest
I think we've got to be comfortable that
we know what we stand for
um that's not to say we we won't do
anything moving forward if the timing's
right and if it's right but I think if
we're rushing to be seen to be doing
something then we could make an error
um
which doesn't land well and um I think
at this moment in time for the players
and myself especially we've got to be
focusing on the games
I want my players to focus fully on
playing games of football and winning
games and I'm sure Germany now in in
hindsight will probably have the the
same message
our correspondence Aston bunkel is
outside the stadium where Wales will
play later on this morning I'm told
we've just lost that connection to him
he's back Alison you're such a tease
there you are all all looking good there
standing out there in the sunshine in
Doha so um Aleister FIFA have reversed
their ban on Rainbow hats and flags
how's that going down with fans there
yeah it's been done really well I think
most the fans thought that it was a
ridiculous ban in the first place and
there was considerable annoyance
particularly amongst the Welsh team
actually uh the Welsh manager who you
heard from just then was very critical
of FIFA's band calling it ridiculous
after their Opening match but that has
changed now FIFA give us their
assurances that if anybody does want to
wear a rainbow bucket hat or
any kind of clothing in rainbow colors
then they will be allowed in the stadium
they won't be stopped this time we spoke
to Laura McAllister who was the former
Welsh women's footballer who was
famously uh stopped at the security
asked to remove her hat and that was
taken to FIFA and that's partly what has
led to this change of position we spoke
to her about an hour or so ago as Welsh
fans were gathering this morning
yes I will and I was always going to do
that to be honest you know for the
reasons that we gave when we were
stopped on uh Monday night that if we
just give in to the first resistance
there's not much point to have in
principles about inclusion and diversity
so you know I'm very aware that a lot of
friends and and family and other
football fans at home didn't come to
Qatar because they felt it wasn't
somewhere that was safe for LGBT people
or or were opposed to the regime and the
the views on migrant workers and women
and LGBT people so I think those of us
who have a responsibility to stand up
for for them as well in a sense where
their voice sure so yes of course you
know I was always going to wear my
bucket hat and I'll be doing it again
today
well both the managers when we spoke to
them yesterday want to concentrate on
the football now I think to be honest
most the fans that we've spoken to want
to do the same so let's look at the
football uh Wales up first in just a
couple of hours time first thing I would
say Anna it's really hot today I think
it's probably the hottest day since
we've been here and they play at 1pm
local time so it's going to be about as
hot as the day it can throw at them the
stadiums are air conditioned so they'll
hope that that kicks in but Gareth Bale
will become wales's most capped player
in history when he plays today I think
Joe Allen also be in the sides which
will please Welsh fans they'll hope that
they can beat Iran Iran obviously
conceded six against England I think
Welsh fans will be cheering England on
quietly as well the reason being that if
england put a lot of goals to pass the
USA that does wales's chances of
qualifying uh a real deal of good so two
big matches today England USA later on
this evening 10 p.m local time and put
us in a few hours time it's Wales
against Iran
an exciting day of football ahead
Alistair thanks very much indeed for
that and so it's a significant moment
for America's men's team who've been
overshadowed a bit by the success of the
country's female footballers on the
world stage this guy is James Matthews
reports now from Maryland on how some
believe the us can go all the way in
Qatar
[Music]
let's go
the secrets of their success doesn't lie
in any one place but one place to look
is here
I expect energy from everybody the
University of Maryland is a Powerhouse
in America's College production line one
two three
Sasha swarovsky's coaching career spans
the Decades of America's growth from
Fall Guys to contenders
graduates of his have played in the past
five World Cups
let's go
there's a competitiveness about the
American athlete a winning mentality a
toughness that is bred through sometimes
across different sports
Club academies have become the
predominant route here to the sports
highest level
but the U.S college system remains a
pathway to the professional game
20 years ago the United States reached
the quarter-finals of the World Cup they
are players on the big stage albeit
forever in the shadow of the women's
team in this country they've won the
World Cup four times
America's women are the sports
superpowers during part of the years
when soccer scholarships attracted the
best female athletes while men chose
more traditional American Sports
whatever the successes and failures of
the past it's all about the game in
Qatar
I will say USA
USI all the way will win the cup it's
coming home it's called soccer
[Music]
it's gone
here they sing soccer is coming home a
Mickey take on England's Anthem having
been given the beautiful game
they're giving a bit back
James Matthews Sky News in Maryland
lots of football to watch later
meanwhile still come here on the show
The Royal College of nursing's director
for England Patricia Markey will be
joining us very shortly and then after
half past seven I'll be joined by the
founder of not your horn who worked with
the government on the Amendments of the
Online safety bill
foreign
[Music]
ER Prime Ministers Boris Johnson and Liz
truss have joined a back bench rebellion
in an attempt to overturn a ban on
onshore wind farms now that's despite Mr
Johnson supporting the ban when he was
in number 10 well our politics
correspondent robow joins me now so tell
us a little bit about this amendment and
how much support it's getting yeah I
think what we're starting to see from
the kind of state of permanent crisis
we've almost been in for much of this
year in politics the kind of more steady
pace of policy making and legislation
now get going again and I think in that
context this is interesting essentially
this is an amendment that's been put
forward by Simon Clark so an attempt to
change a bill legislation that's going
through Parliament put forward by a
close Ally of Liz truss that would end
the effective ban on onshore wind farms
that's been in place I think since the
David Cameron years of government it's
attracting quite a lot of support how
this works is that there has to be
people sign up to say that they support
these changes and then uh unless the
government caves on it there's a vote
that takes place in the Commons to see
whether more broad broadly um MPS back
it
um what makes this interesting is that
Liz truss and Boris Johnson two former
prime ministers have put their names to
this so really the kind of most
significant thing either of them have
really done
um since they left
um Downing Street the bill that this is
uh changing the leveling up and
regeneration Bill had attracted a bit of
um a rebellion earlier this week as well
on an amendment around planning changes
as well so a thorny Bill a thorny piece
of legislation for Rishi sunak I think
what this tells us politically is that
there are clearly people sat on those
green benches
generally close to the previous
governments and administrations that
even a month or two into Rishi sunx
Premiership are prepared to make a stand
and have a little push back on issues
like this and I think when you're a
government that's trying to push through
controversial policy around tax and is
potentially going into a couple of years
that could be very painful for the
public but also in the eyes of many MPS
putting forward quite unconservative
policies actually this shows you there
is an appetite for Rebellion there and
whilst this may be on a relatively minor
issue now six months a year down the
line you might find some of the same
characters coalescing on a more major
Rebellion on a more major issue and of
course always interesting when it's a
former Prime Ministers and it's Rishi
sunak that's when it's those names
involved it's always going to be
especially interesting isn't it Robert
for the moment thanks very much indeed
we'll be speaking to you a little bit
later on but in the meantime new laws
will give police more criminal Powers
against those who share intimate images
of people online without permission and
those who manipulate pornographic
pictures in an amendment to The Online
safety Bill those found guilty of taking
photos down a woman's top or
manipulating explicit images to look
like someone else could be jailed these
measures will make sure that using the
internet using digital means photographs
video clips with smartphones to
intimidate women to harass them to
embarrass and humiliate them is not only
morally abhorrent but will feel the full
force of the law with prison sentences
to match
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other headlines and a man is due
in court today charged with three counts
of murder after a fire in Nottingham on
Sunday 31 year old Jamie Barrow will
appear before magistrates today after 28
year old fatimata hirandan and her two
children died following a fire at their
home in Clifton
a further 30 million pounds of funding
has been granted to projects aimed at
upgrading the UK's fishing industry the
investment from the government aims to
help with the expansion of facilities
for processing popular fish British Fish
such as Scottish salmon and Cornish
sardines
the number of identity fraud attempts
have increased by more than a fifth over
the past year credit information company
Experian is warning that this could
Spike further over the Christmas period
as Fosters tried to take advantage of
online transactions
the number of people looking to rent has
increased as potential home buyers have
been put off by high mortgage rates
that's according to housing company
right move you found inquiries into
renting were 23 percent higher in
October compared to the same month last
year
China has reported a new daily record
number of covert cases for the second
consecutive day almost 40 000 new
infections were registered as Lockdown
measures tightened and mass testing
continues across the country
Elon Musk has announced there will be an
amnesty for suspended accounts on
Twitter from next week the decision
comes after he asked in a poll whether
to allow to allow accounts that haven't
broken the law or engaged in egregious
spam to be reinstated 72 percent voted
in favor
so let's return now to our top story
here this morning the 15th and 20th of
December are the dates that members of
the Royal College of Nursing will walk
out over pay the biggest strike in NHS
history so let's speak to a member of
the unions executive I'm joined Now by
The Royal College of nursing's director
for England Patricia Marquis very good
morning to you Patricia Marquez thanks
so much for talking to us so the first
ever National walkout by your union a
big decision why have you taken it
well our members are sending a very loud
message to the government that things
need to change for nurses in their NHS
so we got a pay award this year of 1400
pounds which may sound a lot to people
but actually nursing pay has fallen
behind over the last 10 years by around
the rate of inflation plus five percent
so our members are hugely disappointed
that they didn't get anywhere near what
they needed to take their salaries back
to the level they were 10 years ago and
what's really worrying them is the
impact that that's having on patient
care there aren't enough nurses and
nursing staff to deliver the care that's
needed so patients are waiting too long
for their operations they're waiting for
ambulances they're waiting for beds and
it just is not safe for patients any
longer and nurses are saying we've had
enough we can't continue something needs
to change
and yet the health secretary for England
uh Steve Barkley would say that what
you're asking for effectively 19.2
percent of a pay rise costing 10 billion
pounds a year just simply isn't
affordable it's not realistic is it
so we we think it is realistic in terms
of the country needs to have more
nursing staff to be able to deliver the
services that the public need
so it's a choice that the government
needs to make but what we need to do now
is get back around the table and that's
the disappointment for us our members
sent this message a good few weeks ago
now to the health ministers and health
secretary and yet he's refused to talk
to us about the things that matter to
our members pay and patient safety and
really we can't we won't be able to move
this forward unless we do have
negotiations so we ask him again to come
back to the table to have some serious
negotiations about the things that need
to change to increase the number of
nurses in the workforce and increase the
amount and safety of care that people
can deliver
so if the health secretary Steve Barkley
has yet to meaningfully engage with you
over these negotiations what makes you
think that strike action will change
that
well I think we've tried talking and
talking and talking over years but the
government just hasn't listened and so
our members are telling us very loudly
now we can't just continue trying to
write letters and have conversations and
and they've they've given up that that's
going to work and we gave another few
weeks chance to see if things would
change with the signal of strikes with
the resounding message that the members
sent when they voted but that hasn't yet
worked and so it's with a really heavy
heart that we have had to now announce
dates in December when our members will
go on strike across the UK
well yes and how worried are you about
the impact on patients could people be
put in danger because of these strikes
well we found that patients are being
put in danger every single day and
actually when we take strike action we
will ensure that safety is is as it is
now so that patients are safe that there
is access to Emergency Services to make
sure that people
um you know life and limb services are
maintained but of course the strike is
going to be disruptive and we
acknowledge that but there is no point
in a striking unless it disrupts but
that disruption has got to send a strong
message to the government that they need
to talk and that we mean business and
that members mean business but we will
do it safely
well yes and talking of that disruption
this comes as there are seven million
people in England waiting for treatment
that's a record high this is only going
to make matters worse isn't it
I think we have to face the facts that a
day or two of strike action really is
not the issue the issue is years and
years of underfunding these waiting
lists have not grown to this level as a
result of nurses taking strike action
they've grown to this level in part
because of covid but largely over the
last 10 years with the underfunding the
reduction in the number of staff that
there are to deliver Services resulting
in increasing waiting lists increasing
waiting times
etc etc so no our strikes are not going
to make much difference to that the
problem is years of underfunding and the
action needs to happen now to improve
that
so what's your message to the patients
whose surgeries or treatments are going
to be canceled because of this strike
we're doing this for you this is about
nurses standing up for themselves but
also critically for patients
we know that the public support nursing
staff in general and we know they
support us through this action so we
want you to come on this journey with us
we are sorry for any disruption that's
caused but actually unless we do this we
don't see any Prospect of things
changing anytime soon
just a couple of questions on the the
process why did you choose to
regionalize the voting process was that
because you knew you didn't have the
numbers for a national vote
we think that members should have a
choice at local level and that's what
members have done they've taken that
choice at local level we also operate in
four countries across the UK and all
have different Health Systems and
different devolved responsibilities so
we decided to do that because of those
reasons and and as has been shown there
is stronger feeling in some areas than
others but even in the areas that didn't
get over the 50 levels set by the
government the numbers were huge in the
40 48 49 so we were very close and
members have spoken loudly across the
country even if they're not in a
position to take strike action they're
still sending that strong message where
people voted most times it was 80 90
percent of them voting yes to strike
and your strike one of one of the days
that you've named the 15th of December
comes in the same week as postal strikes
and Railway strikes has there been any
coordination with other unions over the
timing of your walkout
no there hasn't
um and in fact it may not look the same
if we were coordinating the reality is
that workers across the country are
sending a message to the government to
say that things that you know the salary
Rises that are being paid and the
threats to jobs in other sectors not for
us but in other sectors are really
having an impact so no there's not been
any coordination we are working as the
Royal College of Nursing on our own at
the moment
um and obviously other NHS unions sorry
Health unions are also currently
balloting their members so they may also
after Christmas be considering strike
action themselves
well Patricia Marquis a director for
England of the RCN thanks very much
indeed for talking to us here this
morning we appreciate it thank you
let's take a look now what the weather's
up to
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well today will be somewhat drier and
brighter but the weekend will bring more
wet and windy spells of weather our way
it's going to be mostly bright but
chilly first thing with a local Frost in
land there'll be some showers mainly in
the North and the West overall today it
will bring more in the way of Sunny
spells and fewer showers temperatures
will be around average but that does
feel much colder now especially after
the recent mild weather and the showers
will be heaviest and most frequent
across the windier Northwest
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now is it where's Wally no it's the
Macy's Thanksgiving March in New York
City this might explain what I'm talking
about uh yesterday marked the 96th
annual event to kick off the holiday
season and it began bright and early
just before 9 A.M in Central Park one
person didn't get the memo it's a 2.5
mile route winding around the city and
ended up at Macy's Herald Square on 7th
Avenue
and keeping in the festive mood is
beginning to look a lot like Christmas
at Windsor Castle
that's not winter castle I think that
might be Macy's Royal collection trust
staff have finished putting the
finishing touches on the Christmas tree
in the Crimson room that's Windsor
Castle so have you got your Christmas
tree up there are Christmas trees up
here I mine doesn't go up until a few
days before but largely because
I'm really disorganized anyway do stay
with us coming up here on Sky News
breakfast we're going to be speaking to
the founder of the not your Pawn
campaign after changes have been made to
the Online safety Bill to ban down
blousing and deep fake pornography more
coming up
foreign
[Music]
down blousing images and deep fake
pornography shared without consent in an
amendment to The Online safety Bill
those found guilty of taking photos down
a woman's top or manipulating explicit
images to look like someone else could
be jailed
well to get some reaction I'm joined now
by the founder of not your Pawn Kate
Isaacs who work with the government on
the amendments to the Online safety bill
so very good morning to you thanks so
much for coming in and talking to us so
first of all your reaction to this
tightening up of the law here it's
absolutely welcomed I think this is
something we've been calling on for such
a long time now and unfortunately
technology moves so quickly we're
already lagging a bit behind but I think
we're moving in the right direction and
the only concern I have at the moment is
whether we actually put it into law and
properly because obviously these are
announcements and it and it's not
legally binding at the moment so you
need that to push forward and you have
had discussions with the government
haven't you so what's your message been
to them about priorities I think a lot
of it when it comes to things like
image-based sexual abuse and the current
laws we have in place there are a lot of
loopholes that mean that prosecutions
don't tend to happen very frequently so
it's all about kind of closing those
loopholes that exist and broadening the
terms and also adjusting that
legislative process because as you can
imagine the legislative a process in
this country is incredibly slow and
technology is incredibly fast and so
things like deep fake technology is so
accessible now if we don't move quick
enough if we don't put these into actual
laws these proposals very quickly we're
just going to be lagging behind again
and they won't be as relevant and you've
been campaigning on this for for a long
time now haven't you what got you
started with that so I started the not
your porn campaign back in 2019 when a
friend of mine ended up on a very
popular porn website without her consent
her icard account was hacked and she
ended up um trending on there I found
that it was really difficult to get that
video down and I started to do my own
investigations into the moderation that
was happening on these platforms or lack
of and I started talking to the ministry
of Justice about how what the laws what
the existing laws were at the time which
were very very loose and decided I
wanted to do something about it and so
it started campaigning for platform
liability went after a platform that
regularly did not moderate their content
frequent currently and as a result we
managed to get about 80 of that content
taken down which was about 10 million
videos at the time which was huge but
unfortunately after that I became a bit
of a Target on Twitter myself yeah and
and we talked about deep fake that's
when your face is put on somebody else's
body and you can only imagine what they
can do with those images and that
happened to you didn't it yeah so what
was that like for you to find out about
it was very scary I think a lot of
people were really
um they were celebratory of the changes
that the platform was making I think
most people can agree that porn if it's
not consenting by an adult or of
children we would I hope the majority
would agree that that's horrendous so
having that removed from that platform
was a really big win but unfortunately
there was a very small minority of very
loud people on Twitter who decided that
they wanted to silence me and the Deep
fake was part of that they shared my
home address online and threatened to
attack me and film it and upload it and
they put a an interview that I had done
from the campaign into a deep fake
pornography film with the narrative that
I myself was in a porn film and I
regretted it and that was why I wanted
to get it off the internet and it was
incredibly realistic to the point where
I even questioned whether that was me
for a few seconds which is obviously
very scary as a woman to not remember
having sex with someone that that was
terrifying in itself but then when I
realized it was a manipulated image but
it was so realistic that actually it
didn't really matter that it was fake
because it looked so real and perception
is reality right so yeah it was really
distressing and it felt very very
violating to have my identity use in a
way that I didn't consent to and this is
something that mostly happens to
celebrities and people in the public eye
not anymore I think it used to
definitely I think in terms of you know
if we think about leaked sex tapes it
tends to be that celebrity leaked sex
tape narrative and we've seen that shift
massively over the last decade and
that's kind of happening with deep fakes
now it used to be with deep fake
technology that you had to have some
sort of specialist skills to do it much
like it used to be with Photoshop to be
able to be able to edit an image and now
you can download an app that you know
you can change your face structure in a
click of a button and that's how That's
How Far We've progress with deep fake
apps as well so anyone can do it it's
incredibly accessible and so they're
doing it to their colleagues their work
friends anyone that they want to sort of
enjoy in that way or threaten or
um intimidate and unfortunately it's
happening to I mean if you have an image
of yourself or a video of yourself
online you are a Target unfortunately so
and just you saying how fast everything
is changing that reminder of the point
that you made that technology is moving
very fast and it is a real challenge to
make sure the law keeps up with that are
you confident that in future it will and
optimistic but not naive and I think
that there definitely needs to be a
change in the legislative system and
I'll continue to work on that and fight
for that in the time being I I really
welcome these announcements they've been
a long time coming and but we really
need action at this point and we need to
make sure that any law that we do put in
place has platform liability in there as
well which isn't mentioned in the
proposed legislation yet but also that
we can kind have increased and broaden
the terms of what image-based sexual
abuse looks like so we can keep up and
we can make sure these are based on
definitions that we could apply new
technology to and if we do that
fantastic if we don't we are going to be
doing what we've been doing for the last
20 years and just playing catch up okay
so we really appreciate you coming in to
talk about it thanks very much indeed
thank you for having me now retail
experts have predicted that the cost of
living crisis May dampen this year's
Black Friday sales Rush this is the
first festive season for three years
without any covered restrictions so
let's discuss this a little bit further
now here to talk about it with me is Ed
Connelly Who's chief operations officer
at Curry's Central store on Oxford
Street in London and also joining me is
Claire seal a personal finance expert so
a very good morning to both of you nice
to talk to you this morning to start
with you um Ed Connelly just how big a
deal is Black Friday to a retailer like
you how important is it a day in terms
of of your takings over the course of
the year
well it's a very important moment for us
and for our customers to put it in some
type of context
we would expect to take a full average
week sales in just one day
so it is pick for us and we know it's
huge for our customers a real fixture in
customers calendars and they look to US
every year to produce to produce a real
show for them
is it quite useful clearing stock as
well
we don't actually use this state to
clear stock so their current lines that
we we work on throughout the year to
bring you know this year we're bringing
two and a half thousand new deals to
customers so we actually clear our
stocks later in the calendar this is all
about New Stock and Innovation and and
new products for Christmas
and
uh
um this is a time when we're hearing so
much about the cost of living Rises and
our bills all going up how much of an
impact do you think that'll have on this
year's sales
so I think people are definitely
planning to be a bit more careful with
how they spend and a bit more planned
about things people may be sort of
relying on credit a bit more but
actually I think some of the steps from
Currys said that still to over
two-thirds of people are planning on
spending on a debit card
um with um sort of I think you know
about 20 of people looking to to finance
it with credit
um so it's just going to be about I
think being a bit more careful a bit
more planned with those purchases
focusing on quality as well and I think
that's something where it's really great
to look at reviews if you're shopping in
store definitely grab someone to ask you
know
um most of the people who are working
especially in Tech are experts and so I
think it's just going to be really about
just being careful being planned I would
definitely advise people if you are
going to use credit have a plan to pay
it off I've fallen foul of not doing
that myself in the past
um and it's just a really good idea not
to set yourself up for you know a
headache going into 2023 for for one
weekend but it can be a really good
opportunity to to grab some Essentials
or Christmas gifts at the best price and
using kind of the safest financing
options
and Ed Connelly I mean to what extent do
you think the fact that there is a cost
of living crisis will hit your sales or
do you think in fact people will think
well this is the time when I should buy
so actually you may find that it's a
bigger year than usual what what's your
prediction
I guess we'll find out later today but I
my guess is that customers who haven't
been able to participate fully in Black
Friday for the last couple of years will
really want to engage with it there's
definitely a buzz which has been
building throughout the week millions of
people visiting our website our stores
are expecting a lot of football today so
we are definitely set up for a very big
day we're expecting to engage millions
of customers in the deal set that we've
got
would you and how wary should customers
be at claired in all the sales given the
fact that the consumer Group which had
talked about just one in seven deals
offering real discounts they say that
generally a deals should be taken with a
pinch of sold is that good advice do you
think
yeah I think it's definitely always a
really great idea to kind of keep your
wits about you and you know I think
quite a lot of people are Savvy to it
now so a lot of people will have been
tracking the price of things and there's
technology that you can use to do that
um but also I think it like I said
before it's really about focusing on um
you know the the quality of things and
making sure that you're getting the
right product at a good price rather
than going for something that might
appear to be kind of
um a really good deal but might not last
you
um quite as long so I mean I think it's
a really good idea to be switched on to
be kind of aware of what the prices of
things have been
um and to just make sure you know also
it like make sure that it's worth it to
you obviously Martin Lewis says that you
know if you buy something at 50 off and
you were going to buy it anyway
um you save 50 percent uh but if you
weren't gonna buy it anyway and you buy
it just because it's on sale you you
have it's cost you a hundred percent so
I think it's worth keeping in mind as a
rule of them yeah that is a good rule of
thumb and something that I've been
guilty of of not having in mind when
I've seen some Bargains it's so easy to
do isn't it we really appreciate your
time both of you this morning Ed
Connelly from Currys and uh Claire seal
personal finance experts some some good
advice there thanks very much indeed for
talking to us thank you
thank you
so time now to check out what the
weather's up to
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
well today will be somewhat brighter and
drier but the weekend will bring more
wet and windy spells of weather our way
I'm afraid to say it's going to be
mostly bright but chilly first thing
with a local land Frost or local Frost
rather in land there'll be some showers
mainly in the North and the West overall
today will bring in the way of Sunny
spells and fewer showers temperatures
will be around average but that does
feel much colder now especially after
the recent mild weather
the showers will be heaviest and most
frequent across the windier North West
but these should tend to ease later and
showers will clear Northwest Scotland
tonight to leave most places dry and
Breezy however Cloud will increase in
the west later bringing rain to parts of
Ireland
that's our next wet and windy spell
which will move eastwards during
Saturday bringing a risk of gales for
Irish seacoasts it'll turn milder not
that you'll notice in the wind and the
rain a Saturday's rain band will
erratically clear eastwards on Sunday to
leave some Sunny spells and some
glossary showers
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now then just have time to tell you
about London seeing what they've been up
to they've had a very special delivery
just in time for Christmas
it's kiburi an 18 year old lowland
gorilla who was inside that crate a
flown over from Tenerife as part of an
international breeding program for
endangered species now he was given VIP
treatment by DHL as you can see there
for the 1900 mile Journey traveling in
that custom built crate supported by a
dedicated team of zookeepers and later
on we're going to be talking to you one
of those zookeepers about his arrival
here in the UK and what the plans are
next and also how is Journey suited him
do stay with us here on Sky News
breakfast we're going to be hearing from
the labor party in just a moment as
nurses announce they're going to be
striking for two days next month
foreign